progress in the sexual abuse case
against prince andrew of the royal
family as you may know virginia juffrey
has accused prince andrew of abusing her
as a minor in connection with jeffrey
epstein and so she has been trying to
personally serve prince andrew with the
lawsuit paper so that she can continue
in her lawsuit in new york and not
surprisingly prince andrew has been
dodging service you probably know that
when you file a lawsuit you need to
usually personally hand these service
papers to the defendant before you can
begin the lawsuit itself and sometimes
it's really hard to serve people
especially if they are evading service
and in this particular case the court
granted jewfrey's motion for what's
called alternative service saying that
she had tried everything to serve this
guy but he's not making himself
available he almost certainly has
knowledge of this lawsuit so alternative
means can be used but in a twist
basically the day after juffrey was able
to personally serve the prince at a
private club in the uk so it looks like
he's going to be a part of this lawsuit
and we will see them
in court